Have you been in a GPS fight with someone
in the car?
We need to listen to the GPS!!
No we don’t I know where we’re going just
read the signs!
I love my GPS, sometimes to a fault.
And now ... scientists know exactly what’s
going on inside our brains when we rely on
navigation apps to guide us from point A to
point B.
*We* go on autopilot.
In the UK, volunteers underwent a series of
simulated tests while fMRIs captured their
brain activity.
Participants were shown movies of where they
were, given a goal of where to go, and then
told to either make a left or a right to reach
their end destination.
When the volunteers were navigating on their
own -- without GPS -- researchers noted spikes
of activity in the hippocampus, which is involved
in memory & spatial navigation; and in the
prefrontal cortex, a key area for planning
and decision making.
Then, when the participants *were using GPS
… the hippocampus and prefrontal cortex
went completely inactive.
This told the researchers that, when GPS does
the thinking and planning for you, your brain
basically checks out.
Using the hippocampus is super important,
because we suspect it stores mental maps,
sort of like our brain’s very own GPS.
It help us remember where we’ve been and
where we’re going in 3-dimensional space.
The hippocampus helps us picture what's in
front of us, and the prefrontal cortex helps
us decide which way we should turn.
These findings corroborate another study which
found that when we rely on GPS, we stare at
our screens way more and disengage from the
outside world.
Do you remember what it was like to drive
before GPS?
We had to work hard to pay attention to our
surroundings, assemble pictures in our heads,
remember landmarks, roads, intersections and
… we had to improvise quicker routes all
on our own.
We had to actually, like…
USE A MAP.
MADE OF PAPER.
And that requires a whole other set of skills!
But when we rely on GPS, we’re focusing
more on the blue lines and dots on a screen
than on the journey itself.
Visualizing our environment through spatial
orientation is a natural ability we all have,
but it’s a use it or lose it type of skill.
And It’s relevant not just for driving … we
use spatial orientation in our daily jobs,
home life, and in all sorts of other tasks.
Plus, flexing our hippocampi can keep our
brains alert and active!
Keeping your brain active can help protect
it from future cognitive impairment due to
afflictions like Alzheimer's disease.
So… think about it.
If your GPS told you to drive straight into
the Pacific Ocean, would you do it?
That’s exaclty what happened to tourists
who found themselves ankle deep in ocean water
after being mislead by their GPS device.
This just shows HOW MUCH we switch into autopilot.
There’ve been plenty of anecdotal hints
that our mechanical co-pilots encourage us
to chuck common sense out the window.
There are cases of people being lured into
lakes, off bridges, down hiking trails and
into the desert by a soothing robotic voice.
(Mine’s got a Australian accent.)
There’s even a phenomenon called Death by
GPS!
Literally, people following their GPS into
peril.
Sure, satellite navigation is incredibly convenient
and comforting, it takes the guesswork out
of navigation.
But, don’t let a little fear of the unknown
deter you from strengthening your prefrontal
cortex and hippocampus!
It might be a good idea to get lost on your
own for a change.
I don’t think I’ll stop listening to my
Australian copilot anytime soon.
What about dogs and cats and birds?
How do they find their way around town without
their own GPS?
Julian knows the way.
You can watch it here.
Are you gonna stop using GPS and give your
brain a workout?
Tell us down in the comment section and please
subscribe for more videos.